who is a professor at celtec and uh the
director of the decision optimization
and learning at caltech laboratory
he has a pretty broad set of research
interests
from you know bandits to uh to robotics
and
as a interesting um mix of more
applied and more theoretical ideas and
in particular we've been talking about
i assume online control today so i would
please join me in welcoming uh
professor all right appreciate it
thank you you can hear me yes okay great
so
uh thank you very much for the
invitation um i'm gonna try to keep this
um as contained as possible so today
i'll be talking about
competitive algorithms for online
control and this talk is really at the
intersection of two topics one is online
control which we've heard a lot about in
the previous talk
and the other one is on competitive
online optimization uh you heard a
little bit about online optimization in
the previous talk
i'm going to talk about it more from a
competitive ratio standpoint now she
also mentioned that the bulk of this
work was done in collaboration with adam
weirman's group at caltech
adam weirman's group has been doing
quite a bit of research in various forms
of competitive online optimization
recently becoming more interested in
control so you know we're really
leveraging their expertise and
developing many of these methods
okay so online optimization so um let's
sort of
go through a cartoon what that looks
like so you start with a state x naught
you observe some function typically
called the hitting cost
and then you want to find choose an x1
the next state that minimizes a
compromise between minimizing the
hitting cost f1
and the switching cost which i'll call c
and then at time step two you receive
another hitting cost function f2
and you've you've already committed to
x1 in the previous time step
and now the goal is to choose an x2 that
minimizes a compromise between
minimizing f2 versus the switching cost
from switching from x2 to x1
so this is a very standard form of
online optimization
and then this process continues until
some time horizon has been reached
and so uh the the the line of online
convex optimization that sort of started
us on this trajectory this is
you know work by adam worman's group is
smooth online comics optimization
and so you have this convex hitting cost
and then you have this movement or
switching costs
and in every time step t you observe the
hitting you observe the hitting cost
function f of t
before you commit to an x of t and so
the interesting thing here
is that you want to design algorithms
that minimize the total cost
of all the future s f sub ts the future
hitting cost that you might observe in
the future
um etc and so
the performance metric is competitive
ratio so this is a little bit different
to regret so for those of you who have
um
are more familiar with regret
competitive ratio is is more about
the the difference in ratio of the cost
achieved by your algorithm
that's making decisions on the fly as is
observing each subsequent f sub t
and then making a decision versus the
offline optimal algorithm the algorithm
gets to observe
a priori the entire sequence of all the
hitting costs up front
and then computes the optimal solution
and minimizes the total cost
and and so that is what the competitive
ratio is
um and so some comments about
competitive ratio
it's a stronger criteria than regret
it's typically much harder to
get a good competitive ratio of results
than let's say sublinear regret
uh because the offline optimal gets to
see the future the bench benchmark
comparing against is a much stronger
benchmark
and so the goal then typically uh is to
try to achieve what's called constant
competitive ratio which means that the
ratio
is constant with respect to the time
horizon hopefully constant
you know with respect to the
dimensionality of the problem so uh the
the strongest results are
are what's called dimension free
constant competitive ratio
which don't depend on the time horizon
of the interaction uh note that
if you have constant competitive ratio
this is the final bullet point on the
slide
that actually means typically linear
regret because you're paying some
constant cost
every time step that's what constant
competitive ratio means so
you could be achieving linear regret
which is you know kind of a vacuous
statement in most regret analysis
settings but still be
still be competitive in terms of
competitive ratio and that's because
we are indeed comparing against a much
stronger benchmark
now one of the reasons why uh my
colleague adam weirman and his
collaborators became interested
in uh smooth online convex optimization
is in this application to sustainable
data centers
where the basic idea is that you know
you have a bunch of workloads
you have renewables um so that's the
green curve here that's the solar
renewables
and you know you want to figure out a
way to
allocate workloads to take maximal
advantage of renewable energy in this
case
let's say solar however you also want to
minimize
the shifting of the workloads because
when you spin up and spin down
servers that's very expensive and so a
complete spin up spin down cycle
is about as expensive in terms of its
wear and tear on the server
as running us running the system sort of
continuously
for several hours so now so that leads
to this build this hitting cost which is
large which is to some extent
predictable you know what the workload
is in the next time step
and a switching cost which is the cost
associated with spinning up and spinning
down servers
and so this was the motivation that led
out awareness group to study
uh online convex optimization where you
have some small
forecasting of the future and of course
this
uh method this class of methods was very
successful and is deployed
in you know a range of real-world
high-performance computing data centers
and compute centers
uh worldwide and so that's what sort of
where the initial
motivation came from my uh interest in
this area
comes from applications to robotics and
control
um so here at caltech i do a lot of work
on robotics and
roboticists here's just one example or
we're trying to do tracking control
under predictable disturbances so we
have a well-specified
dynamical system of a drone in this case
and it's trying to track a trajectory
through
a let's say for now predictable wind
disturbance so this is something we can
actually
experiment with on hardware at caltech
other applications that i've worked on
in the past include things like
tracking the gameplay of let's say a
basketball game scene
while minimizing smoothness oh sorry
well maximizing smoothness because you
don't want your
broadcast camera to be overly jerky you
want it to be smoothly transitioning
because that's what
gives rise to aesthetically pleasing
broadcast footage
so and and and to some extent you can
forecast or predict where the gameplay
might evolve to in the next few time
steps
so these are two examples that motivate
my interest
in in thinking about uh this type of
problem there's another connection i
just want to highlight
was the connection to an area of work
called convex body chasing
and the basic idea of convex body
chasing is you start with a state x
naught
the the world gives you a body that you
need to be inside of in the next time
step
and then in the next and then you pay a
switching cost which is the distance
from x naught to x one
then the next time step the world gives
you a body a convex body that you need
to be inside of
and then you pick an x2 that minimizes
uh well that you know
and you pay a switching cost and so on
and so forth
so this is the convex body chasing
problem and the and the goal is you know
to have an algorithm to choose a
sequence of x's
that uh for any sequence of convex
bodies that are chosen minimizes the
total switching cost
and so the algorithm decision is you
know where do you decide to move without
knowing that all the
entire future sequence of convex bodies
that you may be given to solve this
problem
and so clearly uh you know unlike smooth
online convex optimization
can solve an algorithm for soco can
solve convex body chasing
because you just define your uh you know
your your hitting cost sorry there's a
title here
um as this sort of this sort of
indicator function are you in the region
of the convex body or not an infinite
otherwise
and then you pay the switching cost it
turns out that a convex body chasing
algorithm
can also solve a so-called problem so
you get this two-way reduction
and the direction is a little bit more
complicated and it was uh it was sort of
established by this
i i i think fairly seminal work by
sebastian bubeck and his collaborators
um where you define uh you know
sort of an epigraph style of convex
function to convex body
and then you project back onto the
x-axis
in the next time step to to model the
switching cost and so on and so forth
okay so my interest is in online control
so uh like in the previous talk we have
some sort of dynamical system
and i just want to emphasize that if you
actually work on robotic systems there's
you know there's actually
you know the choice of time
discretization
is actually very important when you get
things working on a real robotic system
um i'm not going to talk about that in
this talk i just want to as an aside
uh and so and typically you know in a
computer science more computer science
style research project
we just assume there's a discretization
but you know that choice of discussion
matters a lot
um so here we have the discrete time
dynamical system um
and the you know the the standard one
that is most commonly studied is the
linear time invariant system lti
where it's you know a we have a you know
the nominal on
unactually dynamics matrix a the
actuated
uh dynamics matrix b and then some
disturbance
um and then you have some additive
control objective
so sum over all your t time steps some
cost
the quadratic cost is in red
and that gives rise to lqr which was
also discussed in the previous talk
which is an lti the simplest form of lqr
is an
linear time invariant system with
additive quadratic control cost
and so um we're going to for the bulk of
this talk focus on things that look like
lqr
and so the types of questions people ask
just broadly speaking
are things like do we know a and b a
priori or must we learn it on the fly
what or otherwise what assumptions can
we make on a and b
is the disturbance w sub t observed
before or after committing to your
control action use of t
what assumptions can we make on w sub
two the disturbance
and how do we measure performance and
for instance regret or competitive ratio
and i realized after hearing the
previous talk that i should also add
can you fully observe the state x of t
or is it partially observed that's a
that's something i should i should also
add to this slide
so you know the assumption that we we're
going to make is that a and b are known
and stabilizable possibly strongly
stabilizable
like like discussed in the previous talk
that the disturbances up to some
forecast horizon is predictable and
bounded
um and we're going to measure
performance using competitive ratio
and so just to recall back to our
tracking control so
the idea here would be like you know if
we could forecast the entire desired
trajectory that this drone should fly
and if we could forecast you know what
the wind disturbances might be in the
future
possibly perfectly possibly imperfectly
with some small error
what should the optimal controller be
how would we compare that against the
offline optimal that could have
forecasted everything in the future
perfectly
and similarly for the sports uh uh
you know um application if we had known
the optimal set of decisions to smoothly
cover um
and broadcast the game with perfect
knowledge of how the gameplay will
unfold into the future how do we compare
against that
so that's the basic idea
and so this is competitive control for
alcoholic problems at each time step t
we observe the state
fully observed and we observe um some uh
estimate of the disturbances uh possibly
imperfect so w hats of t is possibly an
imperfect estimate of wt
possibly a perfect estimate uh this is
uh
and then you know this is essentially a
form of fixed rise and control or very
simple version
of model predictive control and in this
talk
i'll mainly focus on step size one so
you only observe
a w sub t and not the future although we
have i'll just briefly mention some
references
where we extend beyond one step
prediction
you choose your control action and you
repeat and the goal is to minimize
competitive ratio
relative to the offline optimal that
gets to see everything upfront before
choosing the sequence of control actions
some comments about competitive control
versus regret in
uh competitive ratio excuse me versus
regret in the linear
in the control setting so a very common
way of med
to measure performance in this setting
in online control is to measure regret
versus the best static linear controller
which looks something like this so uk is
from your class of linear linear
controllers however
it has been shown by people uh so the
references are in the bottom
by dylan foster and max simchowitz and
by gotham goal and
babachasibi that the best static linear
controller may have
arbitrarily large competitive ratio
versus the all-time optimal certainly
not constant competitive ratio
and so if you're competing as this
weaker benchmark and your
real world application demands that you
you need to have strong competitive
ratio for various practical reasons
then you know measuring regretta versus
the best static linear controller may
not
give you the kind of guarantees that
translate to real world
performance for certain types of
applications
and so i'll i'll walk you through uh
sort of the high level idea of
uh one of our papers uh and then i'll
conclude
and so the way that we um sort of
approach this problem
is the first thing we did was consider a
special case of lqr which we call
input disturbed squared regulator that's
what you see in the in the formula there
where the uh the cost is squared cost
rather than full quadratic cost and the
disturbance is just
in the input control inputs rather than
uh you know full a full disturbance
model
we have a generalization to the general
rqr setting which we are finalizing uh
uh soon but this is the results that we
have published
and we're going to we're going to take
this setting and we're going to do i'm
going to construct a reduction
to a new online convex optimization
setting called online convex
optimization with structured memory
and i should just mention as an aside
that you know actually many robotic
systems are well described by input
disturbance
squared regulators so this work was
recently
or is going to appear at nerfs later
this year
and so this is the setting uh so the way
we do this is we do this reduction
and so here's how the new here's how
online convex optimization with
uh structured memory works uh i should
mention that it is a novel
uh oco setting um
and so you basically convert this input
disturb squared regulator problem
into this form where you have this
hitting cost and the switching cost
and the structured memory arises in the
switching cost
uh where you see um that you see there
and c
sub i indicates the sort of the previous
i time steps
um from time step current time step t
and so the problem is is
this is fully described by you know all
the c sub is up front and then you
get exposed to this sub ts on the fly
and so the basic idea and i won't go
into the details although i think you
can sort of see the high level intuition
just from this
from the slide is that the y sub t is a
transformed representation of the state
x sub t and the choice of p
how far back you look into the past
depends on the dynamics for example are
you doing
single examples of glutamine doing
single integrator double integrator et
cetera
and then you choose the next state y sub
t
indirectly via the control action u sub
two so there's a transformation via
there's a linear transformation
essentially because we're dealing with a
linear dynamical system
and that's how the reduction of works
essentially at a high level
and knowing if you know w sub t exactly
then that exactly defines
uh the uh the hitting cost f sub t if
you know it approximately
then you only know s of t approximately
not exactly
and so that's the that's the that's the
reduction and now i'm gonna
at a high level and now i'm gonna give
you the algorithm which is called
optimistic regularized online balanced
descent and i'll give it to you in three
slides
uh first i'll present online balanced
descent then regularize online
balance and then our algorithm
optimistic whereas online balance
set so online balance sent uh was
proposed from
adam orman's group a few years ago and
so here's how it works in a nutshell
um so you have your previous state y sub
t so now i'm working in the only in the
reduction in online convex optimization
so
now the control aspect is completely
abstracted away for now
we know what the minimizer of the
hitting cost for the next time step is
we can compute that because we observe
it
and we can compute these level stats
and grading descent says well i want to
take a step
you know in the gradient normal for my
previous point
y sub t minus one
balance descent says well okay since i
know you know y
sub f sub t up front i can actually
compute
a step that hits me towards the same
level set
but is closer in terms of minimizing the
switching cost
right so this orange line achieves the
same f sub t
in hitting cost but it minimizes the
switching cost
sorry and that's essentially online
balance to send in a nutshell
greedy or regularized online balance
ascent tick goes one step further
this is an extension from adam worman's
group um
where after you take this on and balance
the sten step you take another step
directly towards the minimizer so your y
sub t now
is you take it you take this on balance
descent step and then you take another
small step directly towards the
minimizer
and it turns out that you know this
cartoon which is called greedy
on the balance set can be made
equivalent to
solving a regularized optimization
problem that that um
you see up front you see in the red
excuse me
and optimistic regularized online
balance set is the setting where okay we
don't actually observe the disturbances
exactly
we only observe it approximately so it
belongs to some confidence set omega sub
t
what that means is that f sub t is
actually only approximately known we
don't know exactly what f sub t
is and so optimistic rlbd basically says
well we're going to
choose the w sub t within this common
set optimistic that minimizes the total
cost
so we're going to choose so that that
gets compiled through the reduction to
an fct that minimizes the total cost
otherwise it's just and then we just
call our obd multiple times
that's the basic idea and then you know
you can get a competitive ratio that
looks like this is this is a simplified
form
uh the full uh for the full expression
is a bit more complicated
it is the the thing i just want to
emphasize is that this is a constant
competitive ratio
it does not depend on the total time
horizon
and the end of constants here depends on
various properties of the problem
lambda is is one of the lambdas in the
regularized robd
algorithm if you're interested in
details i
invite you to check out our paper that's
appearing in europe's
okay so um just to summarize
uh competitive ratio is a strong
benchmark
uh that is practically relevant for many
robot applications
um through studying competitive control
uh you know we've designed algorithms
for competitive control
uh through a reduction to a new oco
member oco
setting called online convex
optimization with structured memory
we've also been working uh on you know
long-term forecasting so
so knowing more than just the
disturbance in the next time step or the
immediate time step
but future time steps as well and also
with delay whether
if we have delay in our ability to
measure the state
and so we have a sequence of uh a series
of two papers on this
and we've also been working on designing
online algorithms for online
for competitive control in nonlinear
dynamical systems so the bulk of work in
online control has been for linear
dynamical systems
and we've been really focused uh very
recently
on designing algorithms for nonlinear
dynamical systems
and so it requires you know delving a
bit more into control theory
and so our approach is an oracle-based
approach we hope to have a pre-preprint
uh coming out soon on archive
where the oracles are specified from
from control theory
i finally just like to thank my
collaborators especially in the the work
talked about today
ihong and guanya who did the bulk of
that work and the references are below
thank you for your attention
great thank you another really great
talk
um well actually we're now back on time
thank you
and does anyone have any questions i
believe
mary had one question in the chat yeah
what are lambda um yes
so okay good question
so you have to so so um lambda2 so
lambda one
uh let me see if i remember the details
right
so you have to choose uh so this lambda
here which is something you choose
and that you could choose in a way that
minimizes this max of these two terms
um you is is lambda 1
uh and then lambda 2 is i think
typically
set uh according to some properties of
the dynamical
system that are fairly basic
yeah actually i had a question how are
you quantifying the uncertainty and the
error estimates for the w's
yeah so great so you know in the
previous talk uh
uh you know it was assumed that uh
w's are bounded in terms of in terms of
like adversarial across
all possible w sequences so uh you know
similar types of assumptions we made
here so you know of course w is bounded
then the uncertainty in w is also
bounded so omega t is a bounded set
with a known radius if you will
and then they can be uh adversarial yeah
then
and then you know wc it can be chosen
adversarially within that omega t at
each time step
so this particular bound here that i'm
showing is when omega sub t is a
singleton set
so you know wt exactly so an omega sub t
is not a single
set there's an epsilon that's the radius
of this omega t
that also comes into the to the picture
do you have any idea of how good this
constant is are there any lower balance
for this problem or
um
that's probably a question best asked
for adam weirman
um i i certainly there are lower bounds
um
look i mean a trivial lower bound is one
obviously um
uh i think for general i think for
general online context optimization the
lower bound is like
one plus one over
sorry excuse me for for general online
comics optimization lower bound is
uh root square root of d where d is the
dimensionality of the
of the of the of the state space y
and then for convex for for strongly
convex
optimizations which lqr which certain
which many flavors of lqr satisfy it's
one plus
one over square root of m or m is the
strongly convex
parameter
and those are in previous work um
from adam worman's group i think
somebody's from sebastian brubeck and
his collaborators uh
hey you song so hey thanks thanks for
this very nice talk
i think this is very very cool i'm just
i'm just wondering
if you think that all this uh
algorithmic machinery that you're using
in this
vapor is actually all that necessary so
okay
i'm asking this because in these control
problems there are natural movement
costs in the first place already right
so if you're you know changing around
your policy a lot and then you're going
to be like you know
dragging your system up and down and all
sorts of crazy things
are going to happen so you always need
to make sure that you're switching
slowly
where you're switching rarely between
your policies
so do you think that these properties in
existing solutions are not enough like
the ones that
for example naman was explaining in the
previous talk do you think that
it would be possible to get competitive
ratio guarantees for those algorithms
or that you think that these are really
essential these so
i i can't speak for everything that
naman described
um uh
but i will say that for just linear
controllers which was maybe the basic
version of what naman described where
you're comparing the regret against the
best
linear controller in hindsight it is
known
from those two papers referenced below
that they have they can have arbitrarily
bad competitive constant
arbitrarily bad competitor ratio
yeah right but eventually the algorithm
that they use
uses this kind of online learning with
memory uh
right set up and that actually competes
with a richer class which
may be sufficient yeah so i i i don't
know
i don't know i haven't thought enough so
let me ask so let me ask answer your
question in two ways
um you know the one thing that i became
very curious in
in some of my research more generally
speaking
is you know grading descent is a little
bit like follow the leader
and allen's balance descent is a little
bit like be the leader um
just to draw i mean the analogy is not
perfect i don't i don't want it to like
make that analogy right but it's roughly
speaking
right and so we know that be the leader
in in cases where b leader applies is
stronger than follow leader
and so it does require a little bit of
forecasting knowing where you want to go
knowing where the services come from
and and so i would just say that
fundamentally
that's sort of the thing that's going on
and everything else
you know now maybe making my own paper
sound kind of
incremental but everything else that's
going on is sort of
layering on sort of more sophistication
on top of that fundamental idea
right right right gotcha yeah but maybe
now i can say something because
yeah i mean actually i had a question
too um it's uh
so the statement about because i mean
the statement about
the linear controllers uh leading to
sort of arbitrarily large
uh competitive ratios is this true
when sort of your q t q is
large so like is that arbitrary number
coming because your q
is growing great question so
obviously um if q
it does depend on q and r having certain
i don't want to say pathological because
they do a rise in practice
um but you know you can you can
certainly you can certainly just make
assumptions on q
r where it it's not it's not arbitrarily
large
right so that that's what i my
understanding is that i think like
i think if your queue is bounded then in
some sense you always have
it might be a large competitive ratio
but you at least have a bounded
competitive ratio because
in some sense like you can think like
the way i think about it is that like
somehow the optimal policy must sort of
suffer something like summation wt
square
like that's kind of just unavoidable and
then linear policies like cannot like if
they
if they stabilize correctly they should
not like any queue sort of
bounded you should not ever suffer more
than a conflict that
big constant times so in some sense you
should not suffer
more than a big constant of um
comparative ratios right yeah uh
good point so i maybe i should have been
a little bit more careful here arbitrary
large is with respect to a certain
parameter
um and that parameter may not be
relevant for your application
right right right that was there that
was just my so like just to relate it
back to google's point like
like somehow like the sort of the amount
of movement that sort of our algorithm
makes will also kind of
depend upon how large this queue is kind
of assumed to be right like it kind of
represents
uh like sort of how large these uh sort
of functions are so
maybe that kind of answers your question
yeah yeah that's right i mean we've been
running we've been starting to run
experiments of course
and you know we do observe that like
this algorithm
um there are applications where this
algorithm
significantly outperforms the best
static linear control
um can i ask a clay fine question
hey sure uh hi son uh
very nice talk uh so the clarifying
question is about like
maybe the big difference is that whether
the disturbances are predictable or not
right like a lot of times we are not
going to assume like in the regret
formulation that you have any sort of
information
this service is completely unpredictable
it's annoying there's no structure
that's right
and uh then of course uh if it's
predictable you should take intercom the
the disturbances how you can predict
them and and
my understanding was that this is what
this framework is trying to capture
correct more more or less yes correct
yeah
so which is relevant if you take this
linearization viewpoint i guess to know
in your system that these linear systems
are kind of like
approximately or
if you want to solve a tracking problem
uh then the
the desired tracking is there's a way to
formulate the lq tracking problem
that where it's built into the w right
right you know it had a tractory and so
you kind of
yeah yeah so that's why i'm you know i
just clarified just
just to clarify you know i'm really
motivated by solving
these types of practical problems
i mean like the the drone example is
kind of crazy in it because if you
think about the wind as a disturbance
like nothing is predictable there
so it depends exactly yeah like you you
can
you can say that the trajectory and the
dynamics of the plane like in a steady
flow but like not in
uh so yeah so you know this is certainly
this is a conversation
i've had with roboticists um for
several years now and the way that
roboticists here think about the problem
is of course the general problem is
impossible
there are classes of wind conditions or
classes of aerodynamics
where you can say something a little bit
more bounded about what you might expect
to happen
um and that's how they make progress in
designing more sophisticated controllers
so so certainly i agree in the general
case that you know but i think the
aerodynamics and control and robotics
community are a bit
have you know been thinking about how to
sort of create this taxonomy of problems
some which are more tractable than
others and then you could think about
how to impose things like competitive
control
on those classes of problems so that's
the approach that you're trying to
perform yeah suppose there is a gust of
wind but you know you assume that the
wind
you know roughly is static and doesn't
change too much over
from time to time clearly it doesn't
work in a hurricane but i think
but you know uh broadly speaking there
are many instances where if
there's a gust of wind the wind stays
static for a long time period
you should remember that these
controllers are operating in in certain
cases at 500 hertz
right so though so you know at 500 hertz
that means each capital each
time step t is is .0002 seconds i hope
they did the math right um
so um and so there's a certain amount of
predictability of whatever the wind is
at one time step you
it doesn't change much at the next time
step
[Music]
i see so that somehow relates to
this optimism in online learning as well
but okay i guess it's a longer
conversation i guess
like the optimistic arguments in online
learning also trying to
to somehow capture that in which case
you know like you change the argument
time
you change the way you are thinking
about the regret
and like it seems maybe there is some
uh smooth interpolation possible between
these two settings
uh yeah so one instance that we looked
at just just to and sorry
i i i realized we should have an open
discussion now but just one concrete
instance is
omega sub t the uncertainty about the
disturbance
from the wind is whatever the previous
wind measurement was
plus some little error based on your
lipsticks of how well fast the wind
changes from
0.002 seconds yeah
so just just as a concrete example right
yeah
makes sense
okay um maybe before we uh open up into
a general discussion i was wondering if
anyone had any questions specifically
for the monster
because we didn't get a chance to before
uh yeah hi uh i had a query on
on regarding uh uh the
uh uh hitting cost and the uh
switching cost and there is a
change in potential that is uh death
of uh fighty so how does that impact
our theorem i'm not
i i'm not sure i understand the question
i'm sorry
okay uh uh let me uh try to uh rephrase
it so it's the change in uh potential
uh if i look at the paper
uh yeah ah
so i was a bit uh confused with respect
to the positive constant
and the change in potential yeah
so changing potential
um if oh
okay i see um
this might be a discussion that's better
taken offline and
including my students um
i i might struggle to go through
every line in this proof with the level
of sophistication that they might they
can do
good
um any question for amanda
i have ones all right
yes so i had a question yeah so i had a
question to naman so does
so does your setting actually allow the
coasts
and the disturbances to depend on the
interaction history as well
like the past states and the past
controls
or that is not necessarily allowed in
this
um so i mean i guess there are two
answers to it in some sense um
it depends on what you allow on your
competitor in some sense like
like you could really have the game
where like you're playing with an
adversary who's choosing based on
what you're playing and that's legit as
long as in your comparator it's the same
choices
and depending on whether you find that
admissible or not like
the answer is a yes or no like you know
like for instance disturbances right
like
it's unclear if they're being chosen
sort of on like
while you're playing the game why should
you compare yourself to the same
disturbances
in the comparator right so um so in that
sense it is
um yeah the answer is kind of like a
partial yes or a partial position
however you wanted right so i guess
the results continue to hold as stated
right yeah they are meaningful
yeah yeah the result continues to hold
as stated basically like
well you you can choose them as you're
playing the game but your comparator
then has to be on the same choices that
were made before
right so you don't account for the
counterfactuals on this front
yeah in that sense the adaptive
adversary in the
in the counter actual notion of regret
cannot adapt to your sort of choices
there
like at least we don't know how to sort
of handle that case i believe that case
is kind of
extremely hard right yeah yeah gotcha
i have a sorry are you done
yeah yeah thank you thank you i have a
question for noman so i'm really curious
about
that the thing you mentioned very
briefly at the end of your talk about
this application to like medical
um uh monitoring or
i wasn't it was flat oh yeah um sure um
so um so this is something that uh sort
of
um we've been working on in the lab and
then like in this case sort of
like the objective in some sense is
completely sort of clear you kind of
have
like a real ventilator and sort of you
want to design controls to
um
just have the sort of patient follow a
certain
breath pattern that's what you're doing
in sort of ventilator control
right i wasn't quite mentioning sort of
the ventilator thing necessarily as
a as an example or as a potential
application for the theory that i was
actually describing
uh that was so sort of what we're doing
at this point of time is sort of
holistically
kind of approaching the problem but sort
of one approach that sort of we have for
the problem is to sort of learn a
simulator for the ventilator
and that naturally sets up sort of some
notion of disturbance
between some notion of perturbation
between sort of your simulator and your
real world
and there you can sort of hope to apply
these kinds of algorithms and then
maybe one question i had there is that
um i'm not familiar with your work
your groups work on partial
observability so i should really catch
up on that but
it seems to me like that you have to be
a little bit more
i don't know maybe your thoughts on
partial observability in those types of
settings
right so okay this is uh this is not
particularly my work i wasn't involved
but like i am happy to comment on it
um basically um in the case of partial
observability as far as i understand um
essentially what like what you can so
similar to something like what we had
like which is this disturbance action
policy
like what's sufficient is i think they
come up with this notion of uh
they call it nature's wise uh basically
like if indeed sort of
um i sort of executed the system
uh with sort of um like just look at
sort of
various like just make a basis out of
sort of looking at the execution of the
system under various noise and sort of
look at the observation sequences that
you would have observed um
the only this connects to this connects
deeply to sort of this notion that
i personally am not super familiar with
the the eula parameterization
um and you get basically
like the end of the story is that like
making assumptions
like very similar to the assumptions
that we're making
you get very similar results basically
you can get
uh sort of square root t regret rates uh
if you have like a known system uh under
adversarial noise and things like that
um and you could get slightly better
rates if you've got
i guess something that i didn't get to
in my talk you could get like
uh potentially better rates if you have
like strongly convex costs and things
like that but
at the end of the day you sort of
basically you you you can get the same
result
um that we established in the partially
observable case
yeah let me because you asked this
question let me just point to
sort of i guess the work that does it i
guess i can just
link to it and sometimes other people
ask questions
um yeah um
it's uh it's the work by uh max and
kovitzkaran
current singing in lancashire